wie viele Menschen müssten eigentlich im
Moment das Land verlassen 300.000
350.000 400.000 weil sie kann asylstand
muss ich das zu dem zu dem Thema ich
wolle damit nicht zu tun haben richtig
stellen für die Abschiebungen sind die
Landesminister zuständig ich war selber
zuständig in Nordrhein-Westfalen weil
ich das Ausländerrecht damals aus dem
Innenministerium zu uns ins Ministerium
geholt habe
geschoben darf an der Stelle sagen wir
haben in Nordrhein-Westfalen am
stärksten abgeschoben in im Vergleich zu
allen anderen Bundesländer und zwar
nicht nur in absoluten Zahlen sondern
auch vom prozentualen Anteil am Bund
deutlich mehr als wir zahlen hatten ist
nichts worauf ich stolz bin in dem Sinne
weil jeder Abschiebung auf eine
individuelle Härte ist das muss man auch
dazu sagen deswegen ist man spricht man
vielleicht auch eher von von
Rückführungen weil man mit diesem
abschieben in dem in dem Sinne man will
nur jemanden lässt sich loswerden weil
das auch eine schwierige Konnotation hat
dann kann ich die Leute kann ich kann
ich die Leute verstehen aber sie
abgeschoben haben
das ist eben der Punkt wir haben einen
sehr sehr starken Fokus darauf gelegt
auf Gefährder und auf Straftäterinnen
und Straftäter weil uns das besonders
wichtig war und wir hatten gleichzeitig
hatten wir die großzügigste Erlasslage
aller Bundesländer bezüglich gut
integrierter geduldet und damit bin ich
bei ihrer zweiten Frage weil das ist
eine sehr sehr gute 300.000 50.000 sie
spielen darauf an dass es 300.000
vollziehbar ausreisepflichtige gibt und
dann bin ich froh wenn ich das hier mal
erläutern darf weil das ist ein ganz
ganz schwieriger Begriff weil die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger die halten uns ja
als Politiker alle für bekloppten
wenn es heißt vollziehbar
ausreisepflichtig da muss ich den doch
morgen zurückführen können vollziehbar
ausreisepflichtig ist aber ein
technischer Terminus der bedeutet also
es ist ein juristischer Fachbegriff dass
jemand von seinem ausländerrechtlichen
Status also sein Asylverfahren und so
weiter
abgelaufen ist den Rechtsweg beschritten
hat und von daher aus seiner rechtlich
keine dauerhafte Bleibeperspektive hier
hat es kann aber sein dass der hier seit
Jahrzehnten geduldet ist es kann sein
dass derjenige krank ist es kann sein
dass derjenige inhaftiert ist und so
weiter und so fort es gibt sich
verschiedene Fälle und von diesen
geduldeten gibt es eben bei denen die
schon sehr lange hier sind ein Teil der
sich fantastisch integriert hat und da
ist jetzt unser Vorschlag der Ampel über
das Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht zu sagen
die gut integrierten die sich hier
jenseits von Aufenthaltsstatus nie was
zusammen zu Schulden kommen lassen die
strafreise sind die die Sprache gelernt
haben die wollen wir die hier selber
ihren Unterhalt verdienen den wollen wir
eine dauerhafte Perspektive geben und
wollen dann den Fokus darauf legen den
anderen Teil dann stärker zurückzuführen
der andere Teil sind wie viele
können Sie sagen etwas etwas mehr als
die Hälfte davon wird wird es in der
Praxis aber auch trotzdem nicht bei
allen möglich sein wir haben die große
Herausforderung eben mit
Herkunftsländern besser ins Gespräch zu
kommen zu Partnerschaften zu kommen also
wir müssen wie viele wie viele Leute
müssen wir abschieben 150.000 oder
150.000 wie viele sind also bei den bei
den 50.000 kommt dazu wir haben sehr
schlechtes Datenmaterial es kommt auch
dazu ja auch eine ein Versagen über
viele viele Jahre gilt übrigens auch
europaweit das dass das Datenmaterial
nicht wirklich gut ist aber wir können
bei den bei den 50.000 die die keinen
Status haben auf die spielen sie
wahrscheinlich an
bei denen ist es zum Teil so dass da
auch welche dabei sind die bereits
ausgereist sind das sind auch welche
dabei die ohne dudung in Haft sind also
es sind nicht alle eins zu eins
zurückzufinden aber von der größten
Ordnung
die Gefährder die uns ja besonders
betreffen bei ihn wirklich eine Gefahr
ausgeht sind 600 ja und dann sind die
Straffälligen die können wir nicht so
genau benennen bei bin ich wissen wer
ist jetzt wer hat welche Straftaten
sind in den letzten Jahren und kein
Aufenthaltsrecht hat da ist schon auch
unser Anspruch dass wir die zurückführen
das und dass wir da auch Abschiebungen
ermöglichen
rückführungsoffensive und wissen nicht
genau wie viele Leute wir eigentlich
zurückführen wollen
wir haben eine Größenordnung können Sie
sagen von von 50 60.000 wo es
möglicherweise
schneller geht und und eher möglich ist
als bei anderen ja weil es einfach in
der Praxis Funktion in der Praxis
vorhandene Hindernisse gibt die dann
eben nicht dazu führen dass sie
zurückgeführt werden können
ein bisschen scheinlich wenn ich das so
sagen darf weil er stammt sie
schaffen damit dass es ihr Amt gibt und
das ist diese rückführungsoffensive gibt
schön sie Erwartungen die Erwartungen
die bei den Leuten entsteht ist über
Abschiebungen sei kurz mittel oder
langfristig das Thema Flucht und Asyl in
Deutschland
wird aber nicht von keinem Zeitpunkt sie
können sehr gerne aussprechen wenn Sie
möchten was zu keinem Zeitpunkt
ausgesprochen wird von von der
Politikern der Bundesregierung aber
nicht nur der Bundesregierung ist dass
man mit Abschiebungen nur einen
Bruchteil ganz großen komplexen
kann und dass man eigentlich viel früher
ansetzen müsste nämlich bei der Frage
wer kommt wann ins Land warum schaffen
wir es bis heute nicht uns genau
anzusehen wer eigentlich ins Land kommt
in EU kommt wieso funktioniert Dublin
nicht mehr wieso funktioniert sozusagen
im Grunde auch das Ganze schengensystem
dadurch nicht mehr zumindest in Bezug
auf die Flüchtlinge warum kriegen wir es
nicht hin zu registrieren wer an den EU
als Außengrenzen auftaucht und da rein
läuft das wissen wir ja nur bei den
aller aller wenigsten also wir sind
sozusagen die brutal schlechte Datenlage
von der sie sprechen die fängt an dem
Tag an dem jemand die EU betritt und wir
reden hier sozusagen kleinteilig über
die Frage haben wir 600 gefährdet und
kriegen wir da noch irgendwie 50 Leute
abgeschoben ich finde auch man sollte
das wird abschieben verwenden weil wie
sie sagen das ist was hartes das ist im
Zweifel was was was tief ins Leben von
Menschen einschneidet wenn ich da sage
das ist eine Rückführung dann tue ich
diesen Leuten sicher keinen Gefallen
denn diesen Leuten sollte man die
Ehrlichkeit zugutekommen lassen von
Abschiebung zu sprechen
kein semantischen Streit betreiben das
ist das ist aber das ist nicht der Punkt
aber was ich bleibe gerne bei Ihrem bei
ihrem Begriff der Abschiebungen das ist
ich benutze den auch das ist überhaupt
gar keine Frage ich habe nur gesagt es
gibt es gibt Menschen die verbinden mit
Abschiebung so etwas so ein bisschen wie
Abschaum und und sind deswegen
zurückhalten bei den Begriff aber wie
gesagt ich habe ich habe da kein Problem
mit dem mit dem Begriff als solchen es
geht darum es geht nicht darum in erster
Linie zu definieren wie groß ist die
Zahl sondern der Punkt ist es muss
stattfinden weil das große Problem das
große Probleme zum Teil ja schon statt
es muss aber verstärkt stattfinden das
große Problem was wir ja haben ist das
viele glauben dass in dem Moment wo sie
in Europa sind automatisch hier in
dauerhaftes Bleiberecht haben oder dann
eben Dauer dauerhaft hier in Europa
bleiben und deswegen diese ganzen
Risiken auf sich nehmen und auf der
anderen Seite keine regulären
Möglichkeiten sehen und deswegen haben
wir diese vielen Menschen die durch die
Wüste sich durchschlagen da zum Teil
sterben dann offen übers Mittelmeer ist
versuchen zum Teil dort ertrinken und
wenn sie es aber doch beides geschafft
haben dann bei uns in zentralen
unterbringungseinrichtungen landen und
aber eigentlich aus ganz anderen Gründen
nach Europa kommen weil sie hier was aus
ihrem Leben machen wollen und das sind
natürlich in vielen Punkten keine
Menschen die einen eine
schutzgrund bekommen also Asylrecht oder
genau verfüglingskonvention oder
subsidian Schutz oder Abschiebeschutz
diese vier Kategorien gibt es ja sondern
das sind
überwiegend junge Leute die etwas aus
ihrem Leben machen wollen und da müssen
wir sehen wie können wir mit den
Partnerländern auch beispielsweise durch
Vorqualifikation
Chancen schaffen für ein regulären
Zugang um den Druck ein Stück weit
zumindest wird nicht für alle
funktionieren bin da nicht naiv aber wir
können den Migrationsdruck an der Stelle
mit Sicherheit ein Stück weit
kanalisieren Leute kommen auch deswegen
und ich verstehe jeden einzelnen der es
tut weil man ihnen das Gefühl vermittelt
dass wir hierher ist einmal geschafft
hat auch bleiben kann und solange wir
dieses Gefühl vermitteln werden Leute
diese unglaublich gefährlichen Toren auf
sich nehmen werden übers Mittelmeer
kommen werden können gefährlichen Land
roten Konvention ausliefern
dadurch zerstören dass es sich gar nicht
mehr lohnt ins Boot zu steigen weil ich
ein legalen Weg habe wenn ich aus
Nigeria oder aus Kongo oder aus Eritrea
nach Deutschland kommen möchte weil wie
sie sagen sie eine bessere Perspektive
suchen dann habe ich zum Beispiel die
Möglichkeit dank eines von ihnen
ausgehandelt migrationsabkommen
hoffentlich dass ich mich für ein Visum
bewerben kann in meiner in meinem
Heimatland und dann sage ich ich habe
gar keine Ausbildung gemacht ich kann
deutsch lernen statt dass ich die 5000
Euro die diese groß Familie zusammenlegt
für den fittesten jungen Mann in der
Familie damit er durch diese Haare und
übers Mittelmeer kommt und diese 5000
Euro den Schleppern gibt damit er diese
5000 investiert in ein Deutschkurs in
der Hauptstadt in ein Praktikum in einem
Hotel weil der Hotel- und
Gaststättengewerbe in Deutschland sucht
dringend Nachwuchs das wäre mal
Migrationspolitik denn das Problem
beginnt nicht wenn die Leute an den
Grenzen stehen denn dann können wir nur
noch schubsen oder abwehren oder stoßen
das Problem
auseinanderhalten was ist
Arbeitsmigration und was ist
ganz kurz eine der Lebenslügen deswegen
habe ich vorhin ganz bewusst von
Versagen gesprochen mit dem Hund so
lange herumschlagen sagt auch er machen
wenn es ist dass wir so tun als würde
dieses kaputte Asylsystem sozusagen
unser Fachkräfte Problem lösen das ist
kaputt weil wir 60 Aufenthaltstitel
haben in einem Asylgesetz was ganz
einfach ist denn sie kriegt nur wer
individuell verfolgt ist ein individuell
verfolgte Person wegen der politischen
Meinung wegen religiöser Verfolgung
diese Menschen bekommen Asyl in
Deutschland alle anderen sind ent die
Kriegsflüchtlinge im Falle der syrischen
fliegen bleiben trotzdem hier das ist
doch das Thema haben Entschuldigung
warum haben die die Syrer zu 100.000
denn in dieses Asylsystem geschickt da
muss das doch kollabieren das BMF das
Bundesamt für Migration und Flüchtlinge
die Syrer waren Kriegsflüchtlinge für
die gibt es ein humanitäres Kontingent
das haben wir nicht ausgeschöpft wir
haben sie alle ins asyl-system geschickt
natürlich werden die abgelehnt bei den
Syrern sind noch hohe anerkennungsraten
aber jeder andere der als arbeitsmigrant
kommt und hier verpflichtet wird ein
Asylantrag zu stellen endet irgendwann
unter den Hunderttausenden die wir dann
abschieben wollen das ist doch ein
krankes System
[Musik]
zweiter Satz war dann wir brauchen ja in
den nächsten Jahren auch so und so viele
Millionen Arbeitskräfte und deswegen ist
Migration wichtig genau wir brauchen
diese beiden Themen und dann kommt vom
flüchtlingsgipfel zurück und das erste
was man sagt wir brauchen Arbeitskräfte
wenn man diese beiden Themen vermengt
das ist der Kardinalfehler jeder
politischen Debatte und jedes
politischen Handel bei diesem Thema und
da kommt jetzt der Stamm ins Spiel für
die normal ganz mal ganz kurz die einmal
die Bestandsaufnahme
die wir uns angeguckt haben auch vor
dieser Sendung also ist es zutreffend
dass wir sagen müssen wenn wir Akzeptanz
für Arbeitsmigration in diesem Land
herstellen wollen dann müssen wir doch
auf der anderen Seite bei denen von dem
wir sagen ihr dürft nicht in diesem Land
bleiben egal aus welchen Gründen keine
Asylgrund oder kriminell geworden
beantragen muss wie auch immer da müssen
wir doch an der Stelle und glaubwürdig
machen indem wir konsequen sind genau so
und wir sind nicht konsequent ent wir
sind wirklich schlechterin und ich ich
trag nur mal ein paar Dinge mal vor
aktuell sie sagen der Standort bestimmt
oder nicht keinerlei Abschiebungen nach
Syrien und das Afghanistan ist richtig
ist richtig in den Iran werden nur in
Einzelfällen Straftäter und Gefährder
abgeschoben
Somalia weigert sich schlicht Landsleute
wieder aufzunehmen
teilweise richtig im Pakistan scheitern
schnelle Abschiebungen hoffe ich an
bürokratischen Hürden in letzter Sekunde
taucht dann irgendwas auf keine
Genehmigung
da sind wir aber auch im intensiven
Gespräch okay Marokko hatte
zwischenzeitlich die diplomatischen
Beziehungen zu Deutschland ganz auf Eis
gelegt darf ich das auch abschieben nur
ganz kurz faktisch unmöglich macht das
ist in der Vergangenheit so gewesen
Herausforderung Guinea hat katzenputsch
gegeben 2021 hat Rückführungen faktisch
eingestellt so Irak
hat den Präsidenten interviewt habe ich
gelesen sagte wir nehmen die Leute nicht
zurück
so
gibt auch bestimmte Dinge
das gehört doch dazu wenn man wenn wir
über die Frage reden lass uns doch bitte
mal ehrlich machen ja also das
funktioniert ganz vielen vielen Stellen
sie werden trotzdem mir zugestehen dass
es auch Gespräche mit Ländern gibt über
die man in der Öffentlichkeit nicht
sprechen kann ja weil das auch ein
entsprechendes diplomatisches Interesse
gibt
verstanden
letzte Woche mit Gerald Knaus mich dazu
intensiv noch mal ausgetauscht wir
wollen den Plan von ihm ja jetzt auch
Praxis Tauglichkeit prüfen und nach
Möglichkeit umsetzen da haben wir die
Situation sie wollen ja gerne zahlen
dass wir sechseinhalb tausend eigentlich
ausreisepflichtige Gambia haben wo aber
die Rückführung sehr sehr schleppend ist
also es gibt momentan indem man in der
Vergangenheit viel Druck auf Gambia
ausgeübt hat gibt es 150 Rückführungen
etwa im Jahr auf der anderen Seite kommt
000 Leute so und die Idee die Idee von
dem von dem Plan von Gerald Knaus ist ja
zu sagen ganz kurz die meisten werden
wir kriegen keinen Aufenthaltstitel das
ja und das sind ungefähr sechseinhalb
tausend der Großteil in
Baden-Württemberg und in Berlin die doch
in der
Kriminalitätsstatistik überproportional
auftauchen oder nicht ist so
das heißt wir wollen Leute hier in
diesem Land straffällig ja natürlich das
ist ja auch die es ist ja auch diese und
was machen wir jetzt mit denen so die
Idee die Idee ist jetzt eine
Partnerschaft mit Gambia zu entwickeln
was auch schon viele Gespräche auch in
Gambia gegeben auch damals schon von der
damaligen Landesregierung in
Baden-Württemberg an die wir jetzt an
die ich persönlich gerne anknüpfen
möchte die Idee ist zu sagen in einem
ersten Schritt nehmt ihr zurück
Straftäter also verurteilte Straftäter
und wir werden dafür einem Teil
derjenigen die hier sind dann einen
legalen Status geben also diejenigen die
sich hier integriert haben die hier
arbeiten und nicht straffällig geworden
sind und wir wollen einen Stichtag
verabreden und nach diesem Stichtag
nehmt ihr alle die jetzt neu erregulär
kommen zurück und dafür bieten wir euch
beispielsweise Visa für Ausbildung
gefragt und so weiter das ist ein Bier
das ist ein ganz ganz kleines Land das
kleinste in Afrika ist das kleinste ganz
junge Demokratie aber der Reiz an der
Geschichte ist auch dass wenn das
funktionieren würde dass dann
möglicherweise auch spannender ist das
auch in einem größeren Stil auch mit
anderen Ländern zu machen wie
beispielsweise die Kreisen ja immer
wieder um das gleiche Problem wir haben
es mit lauter Ländern zu tun mit denen
es ganz schwer ist
Rücknahmeabkommen zu schließen wir haben
also ich habe jetzt gerade eine
Veranstaltung in Brandenburg gesehen da
sagte der brandenburgische Innenminister
wir haben ganz viele Russen die
eigentlich ausreisen müssten Russland
nimmt aber gar niemanden mehr zurück ist
auch eine Situation in der man mit so
einem Land vielleicht gerade nicht so
richtig verhandeln kann wir haben
einfach wahnsinnig viele Staaten und
Syrien ist nur ein Beispiel da wird
nichts vorangehen und jetzt frage ich
sie noch mal Herr standen wie wollen Sie
bei dieser Lage auf der Welt durch
Rückführungen den Leuten wirklich dieses
Problem lösen ich glaube daran liegen
lösen sondern auch sozusagen glaubwürdig
sein wenn es dann um die Frage geht
woher holen wir
Arbeitskräfte Fachkräfte weil das eine
geht nicht ohne das andere da gibt's
tatsächlich eine unmittelbare Verbindung
wenn wir die Akzeptanz von
arbeitseinwanderung oder Migration haben
wollen in diesem Land brauchen wir
Glaubwürdigkeit auf der anderen Seite
auch das Thema es ist meistens
versuchen kurz einzuordnen also wir
werden mit Rückführungen das hatten sie
auch in einer ihrer früheren Sendung ja
hier auch schon als Conclusio
nicht das Problem grundsätzlich lösen
was wir zum Teil jetzt auch in den
Kommunen und so weiter haben das ist der
eine Punkt trotzdem und da gebe ich
Ihnen wiederum recht sie haben
die Notwendigkeit dass sie eine
Konsequenz haben müssen und das ist
etwas wo wir schlichtweg besser werden
müssen das ist überhaupt gar keine Frage
wie gesagt wir haben bereits bei der
abschieberhaft Dinge verändert wir
werden beim Ausreise Gewahrsam Dinge
verändern wenn wenn jemand heute hier
kriminell wird und wir sind uns jetzt
einig nach Afghanistan kann der z.B
nicht abgeschoben werden was machen wir
damit dem ja dann wird der behandelt wie
in Deutschland muss dann inhaftiert
werden sie können nicht einfach jemanden
inhaftieren gerade wir sind ein
Rechtsstaat ja wenn der Strafe geworden
aber vielleicht hat er seine Strafe
abgesessen vielleicht sind wir uns
trotzdem einig oder Gutachter sind sich
eigentlich und sagen der ist dabei
dann ist das bei gefährdern genauso wie
mit deutschen gefährdern die haben wir
ja auch wir haben ja beispielsweise auch
Konvertiten die hier Gefährder sind die
müssen dann entsprechend überwacht
werden das hat ja so häufig in der
Vergangenheit nicht funktioniert sie
wissen dass der Täter von Bock stellt ja
gerade aus dem Gefängnis entlassen
worden richtig ja das sind aber
entschuldigung das sind Dinge die wo man
hinterfragen muss was dort bei den
Behörden gewesen ist ich habe die
Aktenlage nicht ich kenne es wie die
meisten anderen auch Aussehen aus den
Medien und deswegen bin ich dabei
Kollegen schellt immer sehr sehr
vorsichtig weil ich das umgekehrt auch
immer nicht gemacht habe wenn sich Leute
in als ich Landesminister war damit
Urteil bei mir haben aber klar ist doch
dass da Dinge behördenmäßig völlig
falsch gelaufen sind das ist
Dinge untersucht aber das ist ja nicht
das ist ja jetzt nicht der der Punkt um
den es äh hier generell geht ja aber man
darf auch
dass die Leute dann hier im Gefängnis
sitzen bitte wir haben ja relativ hohe
Hürden bevor jemand wirklich ins
Gefängnis muss wir haben in aller Regel
nicht besonders lange Haftzeiten also
natürlich sind die Leute auch irgendwann
wieder draußen wenn sie dann überhaupt
die meistens Gefängnis kommt ja und da
fehlt dann natürlich auch
Nordrhein-Westfalen gemacht haben wir
haben in Nordrhein-Westfalen haben wir
ganz bewusst mit sehr sehr viel
Personalaufwand haben wir gemeinsam mit
den mit den Bezirksregierung
falkonferenzen gemacht und wir haben
immer geguckt gerade bei denjenigen die
die besonders problematisch gewesen sind
ja was können wir da aus seiner
rechtlich noch zusätzlich ausreizen und
es ist natürlich so ein Punkt dass man
dann eben sehen muss was ist dann
beispielsweise mit also Afghanistan und
und Syrien ist im Moment weil es war
keine diplomatische Vertretung haben da
muss ich überwachen da komme ich eben
nicht dran vorbei müssen
wie ein wie ein deutschen Stadt in der
Nähe ich muss ich muss zumindest sehen
dass das wenn jemand sich so
wie gesagt ich kenne den Fall auch nur
aus den Medien aber wenn es eben stimmt
wie es berichtet ist wenn eine ein
solcher Vorstrafenregister gewesen ist
dann setze ich den ich so ohne weiteres
auf die Straße da geht es auch noch um
die Frage wie ist der wie ist der
medizinisch behandelt worden und so
weiter hat das möglicherweise zum
Durchdrehen mit beigebracht beigetragen
und so weiter und so fort das ist da hat
es ein behördenversagen gegeben den muss
ich behandelt wie was was mache ich mit
einem mit einem deutschen strafzette ja
von dem von dem geht ja geht ja auch
weiter weiter gefahren
so ist das bei Afghanistan und und bei
Syrien was ist 10 % dieser 50.000
ausreisepflichtigen ungefähr sagen wir
Leute die sich damit auskennen sind
Georgia
ja mit ähm mit Georgien müssen wir sehen
dass wir sehr sehr bald zu entsprechend
besserem rückführungsmanagement kommt